[Música]
meu nome é confessa maria da silva 4º
ano com preto na sem parar de nina
lutei com a cidade grande e agora eu
moro em paracatu terra 16 vezes em é um
outro sanguíneo e nós tem quatro filhos
anderson crédito robertas marlos
cada um do tipo de comparação que nem de
da não sai cada um duto da mesma mão e ó
mar cada um de um tipo de cada um seguir
seu caminho
nossa família e agradeceu
já tem até net o nome dela amy house
faz tempo que eu ando pelo brasil
contando histórias comparação eu fico
impressionante como é que a minha
história tarefa a história de muitas
pessoas e se ela é tão parecida com a de
que ela gosta tanto
deve ser porque ela se enxerga nela e
não é porque eu tenho pouco estudo que
eu não posso vê-los a comparação dom
couve pouco vou quem encostou isolou
fano a gente vai conhecer na gente mesmo
entendendo o mundo em volta comparação
eu fico pensando por que é que as
pessoas acha que visou a fia
tem que ser uma coisa série
qual é o problema depõe a graça no kg
vai falar
a graça é o tempo inteiro que deixa
qualquer assumir ó o pior que lhe fesa
nassar
foi então que eu descobri que eu podia
ser alto didático-pedagógica
especialista geral ampa tudo conta banda
pc minha prosa na falha palestrando
sobre qualquer assunto
a alegria é meu ofício cozinha e vivendo
para além da gente é muito bom só
palavra talento já conta pra nós que o
treino é do órgão a outra vai ferver
além da lei até mora sozinha e dá
trabalho
[Música]
não é que eu tô aqui hoje necessitade x
palestrando para vocês e faço muito
gosto de ver que a alegria me salva das
dificuldades da vida
as escola podia ser mais alegre
as empresa podia ser mais alegre
o mundo podia ser mais alegre ea minha
maior alegria sacolé foi encontrado o
meu lugar no mundo
é gostoso demais da conta
a gente encontrar lugar da ge no mundo
tite que eu peço à noite e que esse
vírus da alegria que eu ando espalhando
por aí está a contagiar muitas pessoas
ea minha vida como a vida
você estuda que é cheia de acontecimento
triste não é dificuldade preconceito e
muita peleja
mas eu aprendi a livraria tristeza se
nossa e sempre fazem graça cantam nem
sem saber cantar
encontrei um lugar no mundo e pra chegar
ao ponto que eu cheguei como they como
lutei e pra chegar ao ponto que eu
cheguei como lutei como bem quando eu
nasci vem o santo andré se pobre como éu
me resolvo contra que branco me beijou m
de diesel e me traz um caminho que meu
pai e obedeçam graças a esse caminho é
que hoje eu sou mais eu
pois é e para chegar ao ponto que eu
cheguei como dele com votei para chegar
ao ponto que eu cheguei com lutei como
tem onde eu nasci tenho um rio com água
de toda a corrida
a ar e mar a marinha era ir a paraiba da
[Música]
tarde já era dj
e para chegar ao ponto que eu cheguei
como te como lutei e pra chegar ao ponto
que eu cheguei como tem como ei e pra
chegar ao ponto que eu cheguei como te
dá pra chegar ao ponto que eu cheguei
com um agora que esse da mente filha de
beto e alice caçula de 11 irmãos quando
era criança minha mãe dizia que era
muito bem aceita
e era mesmo a alegria a minha maior de
raça e as pessoas acham estranho quando
eu digo que o meu temperamento é
melancólico como assim você é uma
comediante sou e faço palhaçaria pra não
morrer
o melhor fluxo palhaçaria para viver
isso acabou virando o meu ofício
e é disso que eu vivo há mais de 20 anos
fazenda confessa eu consigo falar tudo o
que eu quero eu libero tudo acontece me
ajuda a ser o meu canal de comunicação
com o mundo e humor é a minha ferramenta
de trabalho ser engraçada não é do filho
é só meu meio de dizer as coisas e muita
gente pergunta pra mim como a conversa
surgiu eu acho que ela começou a
acontecer lá atrás a minha vida escolar
foi muito sofrida e as notas eram fracas
e eu fazia só o suficiente para passar
de ano
mas eu sempre fui a pagar só da turma e
aprende usar o meu favor
essa coisa de ser engraçada isso me
ajudava conquistar amigos
os professores gostavam de mim e fui
mascarando a melancolia assim com essa
habilidade de fazer os outros rirem e
quando chegou a hora de escolher a
profissão que eu acho uma das horas mais
difíceis da vida
eu não tinha a menor idéia do que fazer
ao inscrever a educação física
minha mãe que me conhecia muito me
chamou para uma conversa
minha filha nunca teve pegar numa bola
praticar o esporte
a história é essa de educação física vai
fazer teatro oi que mãe aconselhava uma
filha fazer teatro em 1984 a minha e
como típica adolescente não ouvi minha
mãe
insistir no vestibular e na faculdade
foi a mesma coisa
a palhaça da turma e fraca nas notas
a minha falta de habilidade foi tanta
eu fraturei a coluna fazendo exercícios
minha mãe tinha razão aí eu comecei a
sonhar com outra profissão
entrei no conservatório de música aulas
de violão de canto
a história se repetiu
consegui tirar zero na prova teórica e
ganhei um colo um calo nas cordas vocais
aí os 20 anos da minha vida deu uma
virada
a minha mãe morreu aí o bando na escola
e falei vou trabalhar mas fazer o que a
gente não tinha estudo completo não
tinha experiência com nada
comecei a olhar os classificados né
e lá eu vi um anúncio vem disse uma
banca de revista
ó achei aquilo assim possível pra mim
pedir meu irmão ele me ajudou a comprar
banca e achei que a ideia foi boa foi
uma escolha a gente vai escolher umas
coisas e eu acho que foi uma boa escolha
porque lá na banca ou lia muito
fui ler tudo o que eu queria e
conversava muito com as pessoas e eu fui
amadurecendo lembro lhe advém jornal que
nem banana verde e quando a rotina da
banca me batia e eu virava tudo de
cabeça para baixo
as revistas jornais e eu ficava
divertindo lá dentro no povo e na cia e
uma coisa que me deixava assim
impressionada era como notícia ruim
vendia india
eu tentava entender aquilo e descobri
que eu nadaria conta corrente o resto da
minha vida porque eu quero vender
alegria
vinde a banca e foi trabalhar numa
locadora de vídeos
aí a vida de outra virada muito boa
encontrei uma companheira e com ela
abriu o restaurante onde o que menos
importava era comida
o ambiente cultural as pessoas gostavam
daquele ambiente
e ali a gente começou um grupo de teatro
no intervalo dos músicos
eu tirava wentao amarrar um pano no
cabelo colocava um adereço subir no
palco que a gente fazia uns esquetes ea
platéia ria
eu pensava gente fazer isso é mais fácil
e prazeroso qualquer qualquer coisa que
já fiz na minha vida
encontrei meu pote de ouro de mel
achei um amor eo talento
aquilo foi me dando uma coragem e aí eu
comecei a pesquisar com a ajuda de uma
diretora que a mesa diretora até hoje
ela me orientou na pesquisa
eu comecei a pesquisar mulheres fortes
como minha mãe
gravava escutava que e nas roças e fui
construindo a personagem e criando a
minha própria história e uma coisa que
eu acho que foi
fez toda a diferença foi fundamental na
criação da conversa foi a gente colocar
a humanidade nela e não fazer uma
caricatura sabe coisa que fazem muito
com o caipira
a gente resolveu e na linguagem na
sabedoria da simplicidade na intimidade
com a natureza e com tudo que vem dela
aí nós adotamos uma filha
mudamos pra goiânia e passando a viver
de teatro
aí eu ganhei um prêmio nacional de humor
que me levou para a televisão
a coragem cresceu
montamos uma peça com a coragem e o
dinheiro do prêmio e até hoje a gente
circula com ela
21 anos que a gente faz concessa tecendo
prosa bem que minha mãe falou que ela
era piá cento e sorriso a alegria é
maior tem raça
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]